butt lift which is they eventually they
get the they liposuck my extra fat that
i've now earned and then yeah and they
inject it into the body would you want
to get pregnant
i just you know it's a whole thing it's
so it's so we go back and forth a lot
yeah it's scary
it's cool
but and everybody that has kids is like
do it and you're like okay
are you
yeah yeah nice but that's the thing i
feel like everyone's sorted that same
response except for him because he's
really eager to knock anyone up you
really you really won't have a kid his
clock hits the western under the bone
brother how old are you right now 39
yeah so you're ready ready yeah
do you feel ready emotionally
um i think i'll get there whenever it
happens so that's no no well i think
emotionally you just decide to change
it's a massive change yeah do you ever
worry that whoever you bring into this
world might have a really uh rough go in
their lives like 30 years from now
that's what i don't have that at all for
some reason i don't know i just do you
feel financially ready
it's a big leap see that's the thing
like that do you have a car that's safe
enough do you have a place that you live
that's safe enough do you have you got
nine months to figure that out brother
nine months that's all you need yeah is
that how long it takes to make a baby
hey in the midwest if you go if you come
from the midwest you see people a lot a
lot worse off from yeah you you're kids
i do like people straight out of high
school having kids here like they
survive i know but they don't but we
don't live there anymore yeah that's my
point whenever someone says that they're
like back home kids they have kids at
23. it's like back home a house costs 80
000
yeah so that's a massive so a guy's
mortgage back home is
less than a car payment in los angeles
yeah that's a fact that's insane that's
insane so like
those things don't add up to me when
when people make those comparisons the
life
granted you probably make less money
back home if you were doing what you're
doing here back home but
i just it's
it's a lot of it's financially crazy i
know people have two kids and they're
like we're drowning yeah
i saw one kid i'm scared for
but i'm gonna have it and if i can't
handle it i'm just gonna leave
you just take off dude
bye-bye chinese baby that's what i'm
gonna say bye-bye chinese baby
i i love taking care of other people's
kids see i've heard that i know people
that love taking care of other people's
kids but they don't
they don't ever want to have kid
themselves i do want to have a kid i
just
i'm nervous about what the world is me
too i financially support a lot of kids
i financially support right now bobby
four children
three children actually bobby
my niece i sent to private school you
did
here
from the philippines from the
philippines really
how old is she she's 17.
one year
you have one year
okay you pervert you can you wait a year
you sip pervert you can get that mix bus
mix family bus i have another
eight-year-old
ten years ten years george
freak
eve t's all you want you don't don't you
no don't you be eve teasing sicko we
never got to advice do we have we have
been helpful hey i'm a 24 year old that
lives in london
i i my dad used to be emotionally and
physically abusive with me for a very
long time until i turned 17 or so and
could fight back and protect my mom
my mom stayed with him for about three
years ago and he suffered from a stroke
and she's taking care of him now i
haven't spoken to him for a very long
time and i have no idea if i should
forgive him how do you manage to forgive
him and should i try to do the same as
i'm not sure how long he